PAGE RESPONSE, TRUMP, YES, I
THINK SO.
STRZOK SAYS, I'M NOT SURE, OMG.
HE'S AN IDIOT.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
WE JUST CALL YOU DERSH, THAT'S
OUR PRODUCTION NICKNAME.
>> MY STUDENTS CALL ME THAT.
>> Laura: WE ARE JUST COPPING
THIS DUTY ENDS.
THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK,
ABOUT HOW IT ENDANGERS
DEMOCRACY.
HE DRAWS HER FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
THE MAN WHO INVESTIGATED
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON, FORMER
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL AND JUDGE,
KEN STARR.
LET'S START WITH YOU, JUDGE KEN
STARR.
WE'LL GET INTO THESE TEXTS IN
JUST A MOMENT, BUT A QUICK
REACTION FROM BOTH OF YOU, FROM
WHAT WE SAW TONIGHT IN ALABAMA,
LOOKS LIKE A .1% VICTORY BUT
NONETHELESS, A VICTORY FOR A
REJECTION, A REPUDIATION IN ANY
WAY OF THE TRUMP AGENDA OR IS
THIS GENEROUS TO KEEP IT IN THE
LEGALISTIC TERMS?
>> I LOVE THAT.
EXACTLY, A ONE OFF.
ALL POLITICS ARE LOCAL, BUT THAT
WAS ESPECIALLY A LOCAL ELECTION,
IT'S A ONE-TIME ELECTION.
I LOVE THE SUGGESTION THAT THE
SENATOR ELECT, IF HE HOLDS ONTO
THE VICTORY, WE HEARD THAT
REPORT, IS ALREADY A LAME DUCK.
ALABAMA IS A HEAVILY REPUBLICAN
STATE, AND JUDGE MOORE WAS
VIEWED AS A SEVERELY FLAWED
CANDIDATE AND LOOK AT THE TURN
OUT.
TURNOUT WAS SUPPRESSED.
>> Laura: LET'S GO TO
REPUTATION AND THE ONE MAJOR
SENATOR COME OUT
YESTERDAY, HITTING MOORE,
FRIENDS OF MINE IN ALABAMA SAID
THAT TO THE LOT TO SUPPRESS
VOTER TURNOUT IN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY FOR MOORE AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE JUST STAYED HOME.
>> THIS WAS NOT A WIN FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, IT WAS A LOSS FOR
JUDGE MOORE.
IT WAS VERY, VERY PERSONAL.
IT WAS A REFERENDUM ON HARVEY
WEINSTEIN, ON ALL THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT ARE NOW
SWIRLING AROUND SO MANY PEOPLE
IN THE WORLD, AND MOORE COULD
NOT SURVIVE THE ACCUSATIONS THAT
WERE LEVELED AGAINST HIM.
THIS TELLS US NOTHING THAT WOULD
IT IS A COMPLETELY ONE-OFF, I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH MY FRIEND,
KEN STARR, ON THIS ONE.
>> Laura: WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
FROM DOUG JONES IN JUST A MOMENT
AND WE WILL HAVE TO GO TO THAT
WHEN HE SPEAKS.
BUT LET'S GO TO YOU, JUDGE
STARR, ON THE TEXTS FROM PETER
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
INVESTIGATION?
MUELLER STEAM?
MORE TAINTED AFTER READING THESE
ARE LESS?
>> OF COURSE.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS, AND IT REALLY
DOES GO TO BOB MUELLER'S
JUDGMENT.
YOU NEED TO ASSEMBLE A TEAM WHEN
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
INVESTIGATING THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
IT REALLY IS ABOVE REPROACH.
THESE BOOKS HAVE THEIR
>> Laura: I'M SORRY TO